hallo und willkommen zu ZDF heute live
es war das schlimmste Verbrechen in der
jüngeren Geschichte Hamburgs mit diesen
Worten hat Hamburgs Innensenator grote
den Amoklauf vom gestrigen Abend
beschrieben acht Menschen
inklusive dem mutmaßlichen Täter sind
tot acht weitere Menschen sind zum Teil
lebensgefährlich verletzt erschwerend
hinzukommt das ist bereits vor Wochen
einen anonym Hinweis auf eine psychische
Erkrankung des 35-Jährigen schützen
gegeben hat gestern Abend hatte dieser
ein ehemaliges Mitglied der Zeugen
Jehovas nach einer Veranstaltung der
Glaubensgemeinschaft das Feuer eröffnet
nur dem schnellen Erscheinen der Polizei
ist es wohl zu verdanken dass nicht noch
mehr Menschen getötet oder verletzt
wurden heute nun kamen einige namhafte
Politiker an den Tatort um zu
kontrollieren darunter auch
bundesinnenministerin VESA
im Licht des Tages zeigt sich der ganze
Horror der Nacht Bestatter
transportieren die Leichen der Getöteten
aus dem Gebetshaus der Zeugen Jehovas in
Hamburg Alsterdorf ab am Abend zuvor
hatte einen ehemaliges Mitglied der
Gemeinde zunächst mehrere Schüsse vor
dem Gebäude abgefeuert danach hat der
Täter mit der Schusswaffe durch die
Scheibe auf die Veranstaltung eingewirkt
ist im weiteren Verlauf durch das
Fenster in das Gebäude eingedrungen und
der permanenten Schusswaffengebrauch
durch Notrufe alarmiert und zufällig in
der Nähe stürmten spezialkräfte der
Polizei nur wenige Minuten später das
Gebäude für sieben Menschen kam dieser
schnelle Zugriff zwar zu spät acht
verletzt und etwa 20 weitere
Gottesdienstbesucher konnten aber in
Sicherheit gebracht werden
wirklich eine großartige Leistung der
Hamburger Polizei insbesondere auch der
besonderen Einheit der BFE die so
schnell hier vor Ort waren und dich ihr
umsichtiges Handeln und durch ihr
schnelles Handeln vielen Menschen das
Leben retten konnten im ersten Stock
stießen die Einsatzkräfte dann auf die
Leiche des mutmaßlichen Täters und die
Tatwaffe für die besaß Philipp F eine
gültige Waffenbesitzkarte erst im Januar
war der 35-Jährige von der Polizei nach
einem anonymen Hinweis überprüft worden
ein hinweisschreiben von einer bis heute
unbekannten Person mit dem Ziel dieses
Ziel ist in dem Schreiben zum Ausdruck
gebracht das Verhalten und die
waffenrechtlichen Vorschriften in Bezug
auf den Philipp F zu überprüfen eine
Überprüfung ohne größere Beanstandungen
nach der Tat stellte die
Staatsanwaltschaft in seiner Wohnung
dann mehrere hundert Schuss Munition
sicher als Motiv vermuten die Ermittler
private Gründe bei Philipp F handelt es
sich um ein ehemaliges Mitglied dieser
Gemeinde der Zeugen Jehovas welches die
Gemeinde vor etwa anderthalb Jahren
freiwillig aber offenbar nicht im guten
verlassen hat viele Menschen zünden
heute Kerzen anlegen Blumen ab am Ort
der Blut hat das Entsetzen darüber aber
geht weit über Hamburg hinaus
und aus diesem Tat Geschehen ergeben
sich Fragen auch aus der Vorgeschichte
über die wir heute Abend sprechen wollen
auch gerne über eure Fragen Fragen und
Kommentare wie immer gerne an uns per
Mail oder über die Social Media Kanäle
wir sprechen darüber hinaus mit Jan
Henrich zdf-kollege aus der Redaktion
Recht und Justiz und mit Sebastian
Fiedler SPD Bundestagsabgeordneter und
exkriminal Hauptkommissar früher war
auch Vorsitzender des Deutschen Bundes
bzw des Bundes Deutscher Kriminalbeamter
zunächst aber schreibt mal nach Hamburg
zu meinem Kollegen Ralf Zimmermann von
Siefert Ralf die Tat hat Hamburg
logischerweise erschüttert du warst den
ganzen Tag vor Ort inwieweit hat sich
der Schock heute in seiner ganzen
Dimension gezeigt
ja die ganze über der ganzen Stadt lag
heute eigentlich eine Trauer die man
überhaupt nicht kennt in dieser
Liberalen sonst der weltoffen statt aber
heute war es wirklich ganz anders alle
Radiosender hat nur ein Thema alle
Menschen haben nur darüber geredet und
es war wirklich auch ganz vielen
Menschen auch hier natürlich voll allem
besonders hier herum um den Tatort im
Stadtteil Alsterdorf aber auch sonst in
der Stadt
anzumerken dass das wirklich ein ganz
schlimmer Schock ist für die Stadt das
so etwas hier passieren konnte
damit rechnet sowieso niemand aber auch
dass das passieren konnte und warum das
passieren konnte die Gründe dafür die
jetzt geklärt werden müssen die Motive
des Täters die ja noch nicht ganz klar
sind dass alles macht sehr beklommen und
das haben wir auch hier die
bundesinnenministerin wie gerade gesehen
in dem Beitrag von Martin Niessen aber
auch der Hamburger erste Bürgermeister
die zweite Bürgermeisterin Fegebank zum
Ausdruck gebracht und haben vor allem
den Opfern gedacht und sich dafür
ausgesprochen den Angehörigen jetzt
beizustehen und insofern wird Hamburg
sicher noch lange daran zu tragen haben
an diesen an diesem Tag heute und an dem
gestrigen Abend acht Menschen sind tot
darunter der Schütze aber auch ein noch
ungeborenes Baby acht Menschen sind
teilweise erheblich verletzt worden was
weiß man über deren Zustand
die liegen in Krankenhäusern und sind
teilweise sehr schwer verletzt der Täter
ist ja mit einer automatischen Waffe in
dieses Gebäude hier hinter mir
eingedrungen und hat
gezielt auf Menschen aber doch eben wild
um sich geschossen also
insofern sind die Schutzverletzungen die
die Menschen davon getragen haben
ganz schlimm eben in sieben Fällen auch
tödlich gewesen und wie es den einzelnen
Opfern genau geht kann ich natürlich
nicht sagen weil wir mit den Opfern
direkt und auch mit Opferfamilien jetzt
ich jedenfalls heute noch keinen Kontakt
hatte aber auch da
kann man sich nur vorstellen wie schlimm
das ist wenn so eine eigenes eine
einzelne Familie trifft und in diesem
Fall hat sehr viele Familien getroffen
viele junge Menschen übrigens auch
gerade unter den verletzen sind auch
einige sehr junge Menschen der junge
Frauen vor allem
die da
verletzt schwer verletzt worden welches
Bild geben denn die Sicherheitsbehörden
ab es gab ja heute Mittag auch eine
große Pressekonferenz immerhin war man
ja offenbar gestern sehr schnell am
Tatort
ja das war im Grunde ein bisschen Glück
in dem großen Unglück dass
Polizei
Spezialkräfte die tatsächlich
unterstützen bei Terror ein Anti Terror
einsetzen dass die auf dem Weg zurück
ins Präsidium waren ihre Schicht im
Grunde gerade beendet wollten und hier
ganz in der Nähe in Alsterdorf unterwegs
waren und deswegen sehr schnell am
Tatort sein konnten und dann auch eine
ein
Sondereinsatzkommando der Polizei noch
verfügbar war vor der Nachtruhe
sozusagen so dass hier sehr schnell
eingegriffen wurde und es ist viel von
Seiten der Polizei ja nicht ein einziger
Schuss sondern allein durch die
Anwesenheit durch das Eindringen der
Polizei in dieses Gebäude das sehr
schneller eindringen natürlich mit
schwer bewaffnet ist der Täter dann in
die oberen Stockwerke hier geflüchtet
und hat sich dort selbst gerichtet hat
sich das auch selbst getötet insofern
hat man weit Schlimmeres verhindert denn
wir waren in dem Gebäude bis zu 50
Personen ähm und das wäre natürlich
undenkbar und aus
und denkbar gewesen wie das wie das
ausgegangen wäre sorry ich bin schon
kein Problem also einerseits Glück
jedenfalls für die Sicherheitsbehörden
dass man schnell vor Ort sein könnte
andererseits wird auch diskutiert ob man
solchen anonymen hinweisen wie ist sie
ja gab auf die Psyche des Täters nicht
gründlicher nachkommen muss ganz
generell wird das auch in Hamburg noch
diskutiert
ja das war heute ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt darauf der Pressekonferenz die ja
der Innensenator zusammen mit dem
Polizeipräsidenten und den
polizeiführern die auch hier vor Ort
waren gegeben hat der Polizeipräsident
hat im Grunde dieses Dilemma sehr gut
beschrieben Reifen Martin Meyer der
schon sehr lange hier im Amt ist und
sehr erfahren auch mit anderen einsetzen
zu G20 und so weiter der gesagt hat wir
müssen im Grunde eine Rechtsgrundlage
schaffen um Leute die Waffen besitzen
und die Waffen besitzkarten erwerben
schon im ersten Moment das war dann die
Forderung des Innensenators psychisch
testen zu können also man hat keine
Rechtsgrundlage das sagte Maja heute
überhaupt so jemanden wie den äh Täter
in diesem Fall vorher
den die Waffe wegzunehmen oder auch die
Waffenbesitzkarte abzunehmen denn eine
psychische Überprüfung kann auch gerade
aus einer anonymen Quelle gar nicht
durchgezogen werden und das ist
natürlich eine Problematik die die
Polizei hat und wo die Polizei im Grunde
das hat der Polizeipräsident nicht so
klar gesagt aber im Grunde suggeriert
hat da muss die Polizei dringend drüber
nachdenken wie man dieses Problem löst
damit nicht Leute wie dieser Täter
solche schlimmen Verbrechen begehen
können über diese rechtliche und auch
rechtspolitischen Fragen sprechen wir
gleich noch mit unseren weiteren Gästen
ich danke Dir ganz herzlich liebe Grüße
nach Hamburg und ich hoffe du hast dann
auch bald dein wohl verdienten
Feierabend danke schön nach Hamburg Ralf
Zimmermann von Siefert war das für uns
ja liebe liebe Grüße aus einem sehr
traurigen Hamburg heute das kann ich mir
vorstellen ich danke dir
wir sprechen gleich mit unserem
Rechtsexperten wollen aber vorher noch
mal allgemein uns zum Waffenrecht in
Deutschland informieren lassen auch
darüber wie es sich in den letzten
Jahren verändert hat meine Kollegin
Beatrice Steinecke macht das
Paris 13 november 2015 bei den
islamistischen Terroranschlägen sterben
130 Menschen danach soll vieles anders
werden die Europäische Union ändert ihre
feuerwaffenrichtlinie Deutschlands setzt
sie um 2020 wird das deutsche
Waffengesetz geändert in Deutschland
gibt es rund eine Million private
Waffenbesitzer sie müssen alle drei
Jahre eine Zuverlässigkeitsprüfung
absolvieren wenn einer verbotenen oder
verfassungsfeindlichen Vereinigung ist
darf keine Waffe besitzen ebenso
verurteilte Straftäter jeder und jede
wird vom Verfassungsschutz geprüft
Jäger und Sportschützen müssen alle fünf
Jahren neue kontrolliert werden große
Magazine werden verboten neu ist auch
die bundesweit 5,5 Millionen
registrierten Schusswaffen müssen
nachverfolgbar sein von ihre Herstellung
bis zur Vernichtung im nationalen
Waffenregister
19 Februar 2020 der Anschlag in Hanau
der Täter tötet aus rassistischen
Gründen zehn Menschen erwarten psychisch
krank seitdem fordert Innenministerin
Nancy fazer eine Verschärfung des
Waffengesetzes ein Verbot von
halbautomatischen Waffen mehr Austausch
zwischen den Landesbehörden aus CDU und
FDP-Kreisen kommen Gegenstimmen die
deutschen Waffengesetze seien streng
genug doch sie müssten besser umgesetzt
werden
und jetzt ist uns Jan Henrich
zugeschaltet aus der Redaktion Recht und
Justiz des ZDF Jan grüßte schön dass du
bei uns bist der mutmaßliche Amokschütze
das mutmaßlich ob man das noch sagen
muss oder nicht darüber scheiden sich
gerade die Geister hatte eine
Waffenbesitzkarte hat also offenbar die
formalen Voraussetzungen erfüllt aber
zeigt das auch ein bisschen dass Dilemma
sozusagen die Grenzen der
Überprüfbarkeit solche Personen dann
auch auf
ja grundsätzlich kann in diese
waffenbesitzerlaubnis und auch die
Erlaubnis zum Führen einer Waffe
jederzeit wieder widerrufen werden
entzogen werden und zwar immer dann wenn
die Voraussetzungen nicht mehr vorliegen
für die eigentliche Abteilung und da
spielen verschiedene Bereiche eine Rolle
wir haben gerade eben schon gehört da
kann die Zuverlässigkeit überprüft
werden das beinhalte zum Beispiel ob
sich jemand straffällig gemacht hat also
wegen einer Straftat verurteilt wurde
aber auch ob es Vorfälle gab wo sich
jemand verantwortungslos im Umgang mit
Waffen gezeigt hat das ist der eine
Bereich und der andere Bereich ist das
auch die persönliche Eignung überprüft
werden kann da spielt eben rein ob
beispielsweise jemand drogenabhängig
geworden ist oder eben auch eine
psychische Erkrankung theoretisch kann
das alles überprüft werden auf dieser
Aspekte gehen wir gleich noch mal ein
bisschen genauer ein Feuer vielleicht
noch zu einem Statement heute von der
Pressekonferenz der Hamburger
Polizeipräsident Meier der hat sich
geäußert welche Schwierigkeiten ist der
Überprüfung eben das Täters gab und das
obwohl ein anonymer Hinweis auf eben
eine psychische Erkrankung des Mannes
vorlag bei dieser
unangekündigten Kontrolle wurde Philipp
F angetroffen
er zeigte sich kooperativ erteilte
bereitwillig Auskunft das war ein
offenes Gespräch man hat die
waffenrechtlichen Vorschriften dazu
gehört die Verwahrung der Waffe und der
Munition im Tresor
überprüft und die als eingehalten
festgestellt insgesamt gab es bis auf
eine Kleinigkeit bei der ein Projektil
oberhalb der des Tresors lag keinerlei
relevante Beanstandungen die gesamten
Umstände
wiesen auch keinerlei Anhaltspunkte für
die Beamten auf die hätten auf eine
psychische Erkrankung hindeuten können
im Gegenteil man hat ein weiteres
Gespräch über verschiedenste Dinge die
Einrichtung der Wohnung und ähnliche
Dinge mit ihm geführt und ist am Ende
des Tages rausgegangen und hat ihm wegen
der von mir erwähnten kleine wegen des
kleinen Verstoßes eine mündliche
Verwarnung erteilt er hat sich
entschuldigt es war ihm erkennbar
peinlich und dieses Projekt hier wurde
auch sofort im Tresor verschlossen
damit lagen für die vor Ort tätigen
Beamten keine weiteren
rechtlichen Möglichkeiten für
polizeiliche Maßnahmen mehr zugrunde die
Sicherstellung der Waffe nach Paragraph
46 Absatz 4 Waffengesetz oder auch die
Beantragung eines fachpsychologischen
Zeugnisses nach Paragraph 6 Absatz 2
Waffengesetz
verlangen beide Tatsachen und diese
Tatsachen für diese Tatsachen gab es
keine
ausreichende rechtliche Möglichkeit bzw
die Rechtsgrundlage lag nicht vor aber
schlecht nur ein anonymes Schreiben
zugrunde nach
also keine rechtliche Grundlage für
weitere Maßnahmen wenn du es noch mal
auf den Punkt bringen könntest für uns
also warum haben die Hinweise die es gab
nicht ausgereicht um die Tat zu
verhindern bzw um zumindest mal dem
Täter die Waffe wegzunehmen
genau wir haben es gerade eben schon
gehört das Gesetz sieht tatsächlich eine
Möglichkeit vor dass ein solches
psychologisches Gutachten angeordnet
werden kann die jeweilig betroffenen
Personen müssen das dann auch bezahlen
aber das kann eben nicht ohne Grund
angeordnet werden und hier die
Voraussetzung ist dass Bedenken
vorliegen die durch Tatsachen begründet
werden und ein anonymer Hinweis alleine
sind eben keine solchen Tatsachen die
solche Bedenken begründen und die diese
Voraussetzungen erfüllen und deswegen so
zumindest mal heute das was man von den
Ermittlern gehört hat waren diese
Voraussetzungen nicht erfüllt gehen wir
auf die Frage ein von Sven Odendahl über
Facebook also es gab ja wohl
Überprüfungen nach einem Hinweis auf die
mangelnde psychische Unzuverlässigkeit
wie läuft so etwas ab vielleicht
generell mal die Frage nach
psychologischen Überprüfungen wie
funktioniert sowas und bei wem wird
sowas überhaupt gemacht
genau das ist im Grunde genommen eine
waffenrechtliche MPU so wenn das
tatsächlich auch genannt und man kann
sich das auch einen kleinen wenig so
ähnlich vorstellen wie eine MPU die man
auch vom Führerschein kennt also das ist
eine Befragung man muss auch gewisse
Nachweise führen beispielsweise gerade
wenn auch Alkohol und Drogenprobleme
vorgelegen haben und
ja dann wird eben begutachtet und
interessant in dem Zusammenhang ist
tatsächlich auch dass eine solche
Begutachtung schon automatisch bei der
Beantragung von einer waffenrechtlichen
Erlaubnis vorgesehen ist aber eben nicht
bei allen sondern nur bei den unter
25-Jährigen Antragstellern
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung und
Erläuterung Jan Henrich war das für uns
danke schön
ja dann lese ich vielleicht gerade mal
ein zwei Kommentare vor die natürlich
alle auch von großer
Niedergeschlagenheit könnten Toni Toni
schreibt uns über Youtube schlimm meine
Anteilnahme den Opfern und Angehörigen
traurig was in Deutschland los ist und
Nils flüger schreibt uns über Youtube da
sieht man mal wie wenig diese Regelungen
wirken na ja darüber sprechen wir jetzt
unter anderem auch darüber mit Sebastian
Fiedler SPD
Bundestagsabgeordneter und ehemaliger
Kriminalhauptkommissar und ehemaliger
Vorsitzender des Bundes Deutscher
Kriminalbeamter einen schönen guten
Abend
schönen guten Abend Herr Fiedler so wie
sich das tat Geschehen derzeit für sie
darstellt hätten ihre Polizei Kollegen
in Hamburg oder andere Behörden hätten
die irgendwas tun können um diese
konkrete Tat zu verhindern was war ihr
erster Eindruck
mein erster Eindruck mein erster
Eindruck war erstmal dass der Einsatz
Gott sei Dank unter den gegebenen
Umständen noch gut und schnell
vonstatten gegangen ist und das haben
sie ja gerade schon berichtet und
dadurch wahrscheinlich Menschenleben
gerettet worden sind das aber mein
erster Eindruck und nachdem ich jetzt
ihren Gesprächen und Interviews
gelauscht habe drängen sich aber weitere
Eindrücke auf die glaube ich jetzt die
Geschichte noch vervollständigen müssen
denn ich fürchte sie haben einen
wesentlichen Teil sozusagen der jetzt
inzwischen bekannt geworden ist noch
nicht berichtet dann sagen sie gleich
welchen Teil sie meinen dann können wir
vielleicht direkt darauf eingehen
wenn ich die Medienberichte jetzt der
letzten Stunden richtig verfolgt habe
dann ist ja in der Zwischenzeit bekannt
geworden dass der Täter auf seiner
Homepage durchaus einiges über seine
denke verewigt hat und offenbar ja auch
ein Buch geschrieben hat und in diesem
Buch bereitet er offensichtlich eine
sehr gute Ideologie aus er erzählt
darüber dass sozusagen der russische
Angriffskrieg von Gott gegeben über die
Ukraine gebracht worden ist er stört
eine sehr krude sehr homophobe Ideologie
und wenn Sie das jetzt sozusagen noch
mal zusammen denken mit den Themen der
rechtlichen Möglichkeiten dann wird man
möglicherweise zu dem Schluss kommen
müssen wenn also nicht nur die vor Ort
Prüfung stattgefunden hätte sondern wenn
man diese öffentlich zugänglichen
Informationen ebenfalls zu Rate gezogen
hätte dann hätte das Gesetz eine
ausreichende Handlungsgrundlage geboten
um eben ein solches psychologisches
Gutachten einzufordern also ich würde
eher jetzt zum Resümee kommen dass man
hingucken muss warum man auf diesen
Punkt offensichtlich nicht gekommen ist
das ist verständlich lassen Sie uns aber
vielleicht vorher noch über einen
anderen Aspekt sprechen der uns auch
beschäftigt hat der auch sie beschäftigt
hat sie haben darüber auch getwittert
das ist ein Anliegen dass sie haben da
geht es um den
hinweisgeberschutz sie haben geschrieben
der Fall Hamburg zeigt ein weiteres Mal
auf schreckliche Weise auf wie bedeutsam
ein bestmöglicher
hinweisgeberschutz ist vielleicht
erklären Sie unseren Zuschauer noch mal
ganz allgemein was ist damit gemeint
hinweisgeberschutz
damit ist gemein und das bettet sich ein
in eine Diskussion die wir jetzt nun
seit langer Zeit schon haben die
Europäische Union hat eine Richtlinie
erlassen zum Schutz von hinweisgebenden
Personen das sind also Menschen die in
unserer Gesellschaft leben die Hinweise
geben auf große Missstände denken Sie an
die großen Steuerskandale die LUX leaks
um ein Beispiel mal zu nennen denken Sie
an Missstände in Pflegeheimen Dinge
gegeben die vor europäischen Gerichten
hinter verhandelt worden sind denken Sie
an Straftaten ein überwiegender Teil der
Straftaten die die Polizeibehörden
bearbeiten das dürfte so zwischen 80 und
90 Prozent sich bewegen bearbeiten sie
deswegen weil Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Strafanzeigen erstatten und genau diesen
Menschen dürfen keine Repressalien
wieder fahren sie müssen also geschützt
werden wenn sie das in einem Unternehmen
tun dürfen sie nicht deswegen entlassen
werden sie dürfen nicht drangsaliert
werden sie müssen sich vereinfacht
gesprochen in unserer Gesellschaft
sicher fühlen und müssen davon ausgehen
können dass sie die guten im Spiel sind
und das ist deswegen hier ein enger
Zusammenhang der auch politisch im
Moment eine große Rolle spielt weil ich
selbst derjenige für die SPD-Fraktion
gewesen bin der innerhalb der Ampel
dieses Gesetz also zur Umsetzung der
EU-Richtlinie mitverhandelt hat wir
haben uns sehr viel Mühe gegeben
möglichst großen Schutzbereich
hineinzuschreiben mögliche Sicherheit
für hinweisgebende Personen zu verankern
leider hat die Union im Bundesrat das
Thema gekippt und wir haben jetzt in der
kommenden Woche genau das Gesetz noch
mal jetzt zur Befassung im Deutschen
Bundestag und es gibt deswegen diese
Verknüpfung und die muss sich deswegen
mit diesem kleinen Vorspann jetzt zum
aktuellen Fall liefern weil sich ja hier
jemand offensichtlich an die
Waffenbehörden gewandt hat um sehr
konkrete Hinweise wie immer der hat das
aber ganz offensichtlich in einer
Einbahnstraßen Art getan man konnte
nicht auf ihn zugehen ist aber so das
große Unternehmen schon heute über
Systeme verfügen wo man anonym bleiben
kann eine Meldung abgeben kann aber
trotzdem die andere Seite mit dem anonym
Melder der Melderin kommunizieren kann
und das ist etwas glaube für den Blick
nehmen müssen also auch bei solchen
Fragen Hinweise auf Probleme bei Leuten
die waffenrechtliche Erlaubnisse haben
die müssen auch systemisch besser
verankert sein das heißt es muss
Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten mit denen
geben Leute müssen sich sicher fühlen
dass sie auch Hinweise geben weil ein
Großteil der melderinnen und Melder im
Laufe eines solchen Prozesses sich
anschließend auch offenbart das ist ein
weiterer wichtiger Mechanismus der nicht
nur mit diesem Fall zu tun hat sondern
wir denken auch vielleicht noch mal an
Hanau zurück auch da hat es schon
Auffälligkeiten gegeben der Täter von
Hanau hatte sich an Staatsanwälte
gewandt und hatte auch da krude Dinge
aufgeschrieben erinnern uns anders
Umfeld der Reichsbürger Szene und
ähnliches und auch da muss mit Hinweisen
umgegangen werden der Umgang mit
Hinweisen insgesamt ist ein überragendes
Thema an vielen Stellen der Gesellschaft
und taucht jetzt hier wieder als
wichtiger Mechanismus auf also klarer
Appell von ihnen dass es da eine
Verbesserung braucht was den Schutz eben
auch dieser Menschen dieser Informanten
angeht bzw sie hat uns mir Vorgespräch
auch erklärt dass es insgesamt auch eine
größere Anwendungsbreite geben muss für
Situationen auf die das überhaupt dazu
trifft
ja vollkommen Gericht ja richtig
Probleme im aktuellen Fall war ja auch
dass es nur eben diesen einen anonymen
Hinweis gab und dass die Beamten die den
mutmaßlichen Täter besuchten inzwischen
kann man wohl auch von Täter sprechen
keine weiteren Anhaltspunkte für
weitergehende Maßnahmen fanden also
Maßnahmen etwa die Sicherstellung der
Waffe oder die Beantragung eines
psychologischen Zeugnisses was meinen
sie ist denn so ein kurzer Besuch
überhaupt dazu geeignet ein Urteil über
die betreffende Person zu fällen
also ich glaube hier kann man nur
wirklich überhaupt keine Vorwürfe
unterbringen sondern ich glaube hier hat
man wirklich alles richtig gemacht an
der Stelle bis zu dem Punkt was diese
Überprüfung und
Aufbewahrungsmöglichkeiten angeht denn
es gibt die Möglichkeit das ohne
Ankündigung zu machen und so ist es hier
auch passiert das heißt der Täter konnte
nicht wissen dass er überprüft wird und
war auch angetroffen worden die
Aufbewahrung ist kontrolliert und hat
mit ihm entsprechende Gespräche geführt
was ich nur eben sagen würde ist dass
das ein wichtiger Punkt ist bei dem ich
nach stand heute zum Ergebnis komme dass
der guten richtig gemacht worden ist
aber es müssen natürlich auch die
entsprechende Behörden mit so viel
Personal ausgestattet werden dass sie
z.B auch gucken können ob dieser Mensch
eine Internetseite betreibt ob er nach
außen irgendwelche Kunden Ideologien
verbreitet und wenn schon einmal dann
auch noch der Hinweis in diese Richtung
tatsächlich geht dass man auch Zeit und
Gelegenheit hat in einem solchen
Arbeitsumfeld sich noch mal intensiver
solche Menschen anzuschauen nicht nur
durch diese vor Ort Kontrolle wir wissen
tatsächlich dass insgesamt das gilt für
alle Bundesländer dort eine erhebliches
Vollzugsdefizit besteht man muss also
sagen es ist überhaupt keine
Selbstverständlichkeit dass also
regelmäßig solche Kontrollen vor Ort
durchgeführt werden können weil hier
tatsächlich ein erheblicher
Personalbedarf besteht der eben in den
allermeisten oder vielen Waffenbehörden
nicht gedeckt ist
ich lese gerade noch mal ein paar
Kommentare bzw Fragen vor also wer eine
Patrone auf dem Tisch liegen hat so war
das offenbar im Fall dieses Mannes der
hatte im Prinzip seine Waffe und auch
die Munition im Tresor aber eine Patrone
lag wohl oben auf der sollte schon
suspekt sein ist hier eine Meinung und
hier wird in ähnliche Richtung noch
gefragt über Facebook Petra Bösinger
warum haben Sportschützen ihre Waffen
überhaupt zu Hause trainieren sie nicht
im Verein wie wäre es denn wenn man die
dort dann einschließen müsste haben Sie
dazu eine Meinung
ja da habe ich allerdings eine Meinung
zu das ist ein Vorschlag den gibt es
schon ganz ganz lange ich habe ihn heute
auch auf sozialen Medien immer
wiedergefunden da bitte ich nur zu
bedenken was das in der Konsequenz
bedeuten würde das würde dieser
Vorschlag würde bedeuten dass wir bei
Sportvereinen das sind ja tatsächlich
ehrenamtliche Vereine die hier eine gute
Arbeit machen in unserer Gesellschaft
dass wir dort eine Bündelung von
Schusswaffen und Munition hätten wir
müssen der sozusagen
hochsicherheitsräume schaffen in diesen
Sportverein das halte ich für überhaupt
keine kluge Idee sondern dann schaffen
wir ganz neue Sicherheitsrisiken und
Sicherheitsprobleme deswegen glaube ich
ganz grundsätzlich und prinzipiell sind
wirklich die engen Vorgaben die
Sportschützen insbesondere schon haben
richtig ich komme nur auf meinen Punkt
von vorher zurück sie müssen auch
kontrolliert werden können da haben
übrigens Sportschützen überhaupt nichts
gegen wenn die kontrolliert werden aber
sie bemängelt eben selbst dass das
Personal im was eben dafür
verantwortlich ist Erlaubnisse zu
erteilen die zu überprüfen vor Ort
Kontrollen zu machen bei weitem zu
gering ist das ist das aus meiner Sicht
bedeutendste Problem was wir derzeit in
Deutschland an dieser Stelle haben ja
aber das ist gut dass sie den Punkt auch
noch mal ansprechen denn die
Innenministerin die ja wie sie der SPD
angehört will ja nun das Waffenrecht
auch gerne weiter verschärfen da geht es
etwa um Verbot von bestimmten
haltautomaten halbautomatischen Waffen
aber auch um weitergehender
Auskunftsrechte der Waffenbehörden und
daran wird auch Kritik geübt auch zum
Beispiel von der FDP die eine
Überregulierung befürchte bzw eben auch
Hinweis auf den gleichzeitigen
Personalmangel und daher sei der
Vorschlag nicht zielführend was halten
Sie denn von den geplanten Änderungen
vor dem Hintergrund den sie gerade
skizziert haben das ist ohnehin zu
wenige Mitarbeiter gibt
das darf man nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen da halte ich überhaupt nichts
vor und ich kenne diese Argumente man
muss aber eben sehen dass es ja nicht
ein einziger Vorschlag ist sondern ganz
ganz viele Stellschrauben die in dem
Gesetzentwurf jetzt enthalten sind und
ich verweise noch einmal auf diesen
Punkt Hanau dass eine etwas andere
Rangehensweise da geht es um den
Vorschlag den ich schon vor vielen
Jahren gemacht habe dass wenn sich Leute
mit etwas kruden schreiben und ich kenne
solche weil ich im Innenministerium in
Nordrhein-Westfalen selber solche
Beschwerden mal bearbeitet habe da
kriegen sie also stapelweise Post von
Leuten bei denen sie ohne
medizinische Studium sagen können die
haben als psychisches Problem das
erkennen Sie sofort auf den ersten Blick
und für diese Fälle muss es natürlich
Meldewege geben um überhaupt die
Waffenbehörden in die Lage zu versetzen
davon Kenntnis zu haben und dann
Überprüfung einzuleiten das ist in der
letzten Legislaturperiode wie ich sagen
würde durch eine sehr schmutzige
Kampagne der Waffen Lobby also der
Verbände selbst torpediert worden durch
einen Brief Generator und das hat Horst
Seehof er und insbesondere
Unionsfraktion davon abgehalten
überhaupt Änderungen zu machen das holte
Innenministerin jetzt richtigerweise
nach
die Auffassung des
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordneten ich hätte
eine Frage noch an Sie was das Amok
präventionsnetzwerk das gibt es
tatsächlich angeht
sie hat mir im Vorfeld gesagt dass das
ein Instrument ist das auch eine ganz
wertvolle Aufgabe liefert und leistet
vielleicht könnten sie das unseren
Zuschauern auch noch mal kurz erklären
worum geht es da genau
ja das ist eine ganz lobenswerte
Einrichtung und die muss man bei dieser
Gelegenheit glaube ich immer wieder
unterbringen weil wir befinden uns ja
wieder einer Situation wo die
Bild-Zeitung ist wieder nicht lassen
kann neue Anreize für künftiger Amok
Täter zu liefern indem sie wieder
heißerisch auch noch das Bild des Täters
auf die Titelseiten bringt und das
Gegenteil was man also tatsächlich
präventiv machen kann ist das Amok
präventionsnetzwerk das findet man sehr
leicht bei einer Suche im Internet bei
der Universität Gießen das leitet die
befreundete Professorin Britta
Bannenberg das macht einen
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
im Ehrenamt und dort können sich Leute
in Wenden die in ihrem sozialen Umfeld
Feststellung gemacht haben dass ich
Leute stark verändert haben das Umfeld
bedeutet dorthin Hinweise ausschulen aus
Arbeitsämtern aus dem beruflichen Umfeld
aus der Nachbarschaft ein wo Leute sich
unsicher sind und sagen oh da hat sich
einer wirklich irgendwie krass komisch
verhalten und dies und jenes macht mich
wirklich besorgt in etwa so etwas was
den anonym kleiner Hinweisgeber auch
bewogen hat und dort können sich
Menschen hinwenden das müssen ist da
nicht die Polizeibehörde sondern dann
wird so ein Sachverhalt professionell
eingeschätzt und man kriegt von den
Wissenschaftlern ein Hinweis darauf ob
das tatsächlich ernst zu nehmen ist oder
man kriegt es einen sortiert weil dort
kriminologinnen und Kriminologen
Arbeiten die sich sehr sehr
spezialisiert haben die amokfälle der
Vergangenheit beispielsweise den inuter
ja untersucht haben und
Schlussfolgerungen daraus gezogen haben
und dann im Zweifel wenn es wirklich
ernst zu nehmen ist dann wird von dort
eskaliert an Sicherheitsbehörden das hat
in der Vergangenheit auch erfolgreich
stattgefunden deswegen bin ich dankbar
für diesen Werbeblock weil es gut ist
wenn Leute wissen dass es solch eine
Beratungsmöglichkeit in Deutschland gibt
sagen sie noch mal ganz kurz wo man sich
dahin wenden soll wie heißt diese
Einrichtung genau
wenn man im Internet wenn man wenn man
im Internet sucht Amok
präventionsnetzwerk an der Universität
Gießen findet man das sehr problemlos
hätten wir das auch noch untergebracht
in der Hoffnung das ist selten nötig
sein möge aber man kann es leider nicht
wissen wie der Fall jetzt in Hamburg
auch wieder gezeigt hat vielen Dank
Sebastian Fieber war das für uns SPD
Bundestagsabgeordneter und ehemaliger
Kriminal Hauptkommissare vielen Dank
dafür dass Sie sich die Zeit heute für
uns genommen haben schönen Abend
sehr sehr gerne danke Ihnen auch
Dankeschön und natürlich auch an unsere
Userinnen und User ein herzliches
Dankeschön das war unser Livestream zum
Amoklauf gestern Abend in Hamburg danke
für euer Interesse einen schönen Abend
und einen hoffentlich erholsames
Wochenende bis demnächst ciao